hey youtubers is charlie so this is
gonna be a breakdown of the missy clip
that the BBC just posted they just
confirm that she's coming back for
series 9 they've been filming since
january and i believe Moffat said he had
almost three scripts ready before they
even got started so you should expect
them to start making more casting
announcements in the next few months as
production continues they've already
announced a whole bunch of guest cast so
I'll explain who they are at the end of
the video this is mostly going to be
about the Missy footage in the first two
episodes oh and just because this is my
first Doctor Who video of the year I'm
just doing a spontaneous give away all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card so i'll announce the details
for that at the end of this juicy Apple
remember who hit the Apple was the item
or was it Eve I no idea oh it was the
serpent it was a bit evil anyway I like
apples I'm back so this is a really odd
video that the BBC posted Moffat already
said that Missy was coming back now it's
confirmed usually the first videos that
we get from Doctor Who aren't official
usually it's like someone camping out on
the set when they film outdoors it's
possible that they're getting ready to
film some outdoor Missy scenes or
something like that and that's why they
posted this so that someone wouldn't
leak at first but most important stuff
so episode one we already news called
The Magician's apprentice episode two is
called the witch's familiar it's a
two-part premiere that Missy's gonna be
a big part of we don't know if she's
going to be the main villain in series 9
like she was in series 8 or if she'll
just be a background player I like the
juxtaposition with the titles it might
offer some clues as to what the new
dynamic is going to be between the
doctor Clara and Missy I'm expecting it
to be pretty contained to those three
people I'm not expecting it like some
new character to come along that would
be crazy if missy got her own apprentice
so to speak I don't I don't think that's
going to happen I think Moffat likes to
keep things a little more self-contained
there's no official premiere date on
that first episode but they did say
autumn 2015 so until they get more
specific just expect series night to
premiere about the same time series 8
premiered so in the promo Missy's eating
the Apple commenting on the story of the
biblical Garden of Eden Adam
the beginning of evil the birth of
knowledge you know depending on your
temptation the Apple represents
knowledge as well as evil so let's pick
that apart just looking at it from
Missy's perspective first the garden
could represent that garden in the data
slice the one that she always walked
around and in series eight in the
biblical sense it's also a point of
origin it represents paradise the origin
of man so it could also represent
Gallifrey at least for Missy I mean
that's her idea of paradise depending on
whose perspective you take the doctor
Clara Missy the metaphors changed quite
a bit like paradise for the doctor is
travelling in the TARDIS with his
companion but paradise for Clara might
be life with Danny pink since this is
missy's video we'll start with her so
you could say the doctors Adam missy is
Eve and cars the snake who wants to
destroy Missy's paradise by giving the
Apple to the doctor or when you take the
doctors perspective you could say that
missy is the snake giving Clara the
Apple destroying his paradise destroying
his life in the TARDIS with his
companion Missy's obsessed with the
doctor she wants him all to herself so
she's probably going to try and break
their relationship somehow Missy's only
been confirmed for the first two
episodes so she might just pop up across
series 9 I don't think they make such a
big deal about her if she wasn't going
to come back before the finale but we
have no idea how she's going to figure
into the overarching plot a series 9
like the major story so time this back
to the end of series 8 the garden could
represent Gallifrey just because we're
still looking for Gallifrey doesn't mean
that will actually find it in series 9
but I do think that they'll be dancing
around it you guys can let me know
whether you agree or not but do you feel
like Gallifrey works better as a red
herring like as an idea in the doctors
head in the doctor and Missy's head or
do you think it would be better if they
like literally brought it back into the
Doctor Who universe proper like if the
doctor could set foot on Gallifrey soil
that would mean the Time Lords coming
back and then having to incorporate them
into the story somehow that almost feels
like it would cause more problems than
it would solve like I feel like the only
time they would bring the Time Lords
back proper would be if they were going
to be the major villain or major
protagonist of the season and the
doctors always going to be the main
protagonist of the season if you look at
it in the context of series 8 I mean
they did kind of visit Gallifrey there
was a lot of arguing after that episode
where Clark talked to the doctor as a
boy about about where that shed actually
was it sounded like based on the way the
press talked about it they actually were
on Gallifrey but I
never remember Moffat confirming it
that's always the funny thing with
Moffat explanations like sometimes when
people ask him questions at conventions
he'll answer a question with a question
speaking of which next big question how
did Missy survive the series 8 finale
I'm sure moffatts explanation in the
first couple episodes I'll involve some
comedy but the short answer is her
compact sonic teleported her away
instead of vaporizing her that's why
they had the Blue Beam instead of the
red one it wasn't confirmed whether or
not she had a TARDIS in series 8 it
seemed like she did but what I'd really
like to see is the inside of that TARDIS
the only other explanation for her
jumping around the time would be a
vortex manipulator so that's possible
too but I think a master TARDIS would be
so much more fun here's my big question
for you guys what are some things that
you'd like to see them do with the
master character or the mistress
character however you want to think
about her now that we know she's coming
back why you guys think about that
here's actually some of the confirmed
guest cast they've already announced so
first up is Paul K he's like the first
big guest actor he's going to be playing
someone named Prentiss in the first two
episodes you probably know him as
Thoreau sameer from Game of Thrones he
had this really awesome quote as a kid
in the 1970s the two shows you always
watch where the top of the pops and
doctor who they were unmissable I
actually wrote a song called looking for
Davros in my first punk band and I sang
it like a demented Dalek I got to
represent totp back in the mid-90s and
landing this role on doctor who
completes the dream double and then he
goes on to say peter is a perfect doctor
and I'm loving every minute of the
experience I guess he's already filmed
some of his scenes even the five hours
in makeup what a treat best 50th
birthday present ever that five hours in
makeup just makes it sound like he's
playing an alien character or he's going
to have a lot of prosthetics the rest of
the people they've announced include
Morven Christie who was in grandchester
Archer alley from the missing Colin
McFarlane from EastEnders in Sophie
stone from Midsomer Murders just the way
that they talk about those people in the
press release makes it sound like
they'll appear at least in the first
block of episodes if not the first two
so what I'm probably going to do because
there's no Doctor Who going on right now
and we're ramping up for Game of Thrones
so I'm mostly focusing on that stuff is
I'll wait for like really big Doctor Who
announcements to do bonus videos be sure
to subscribe to get everything just
explain the giveaway I'm gonna announce
the winner whenever I post my next game
of Thrones video since i'm probably
going to post another doctor who video
for a little while the BBC
hasn't really announced whether or not
they're going to do another world tour
or how they're going to promote series
nine but that's probably not going to
start till August regardless so just
expect to hear regular casting
announcements for the next couple of
months we'll probably learned what some
of the other episode titles are right
now there's only four episodes listed on
IMDb we only know the names of the first
two so while you guys wait for more
Doctor Who news just in case you missed
any of it you can click here for all my
Doctor Who series 8 videos and you can
click here to catch up on Game of
Thrones i just posted a Jon Snow video a
little while ago so thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you